now the funny thing is i've been talking
a lot about bill maher on this show and
what's going on with these with these
liberals these lefties that sort of get
it but then don't get it and they never
vote the right way and what do we do
with these people and it's nice that
they're coming around but guys get to
the end of the road etc etc well trevor
noah who's the host of the daily show
and nobody really watches the daily show
anymore but these clips go seemingly
viral it's hard to tell if it's organic
or not but trevor noah was the host of
the daily show and he is you know this
is a guy that just you know a couple
weeks ago was calling for joe rogan to
basically be fired because he sent the
edward and he get he's wrong on pretty
much everything but even he
even trevor noah lefty wrong on
everything trevor noah sees the insanity
of this kyrie irving situation mayor
eric adams has lifted the rule that you
have to be vaccinated to attend indoor
events okay that's gone
but
there is still a rule that you have to
be vaccinated to go to your workplace
so if someone's job is at an indoor
event they can't go to work but they can
show up to work
to watch their colleagues do their thing
yeah
which is exactly what happened this
weekend yeah guys i i don't care
like how covert compliant you are like
this makes zero sense can we agree on
that can we what so kyrie can go inside
not wear a mask even hug a teammate but
he cannot play
i don't get it why does the ball have a
weak immune system what's going on
i mean it's crazy just think about it
kyrie can't play but he can sit in the
stands right like a fan
and then as a fan what happens if he
gets picked to take the half court shot
to win the car can you do that
what are those all right so putting
aside that the guy's just not funny he's
got 20 writers doing that whole thing
okay fine that but it's good to see i
suppose someone waking up however i
think we're gonna see more and more of
this as these rules and regulations are
are so shown to be ridiculous and
nonsensical you're gonna see more of the
liberals than the lefties who got
everything wrong for the last two years
starting to sound somewhat sane and the
question is what what do we kind of do
with them like do we everyone gets very
excited i see this happening all the
time every time a liberal says something
that's not completely like batshit
bananas everyone's like oh my god even
trevor noah and bill maher said it it's
like all right congratulations for being
two years too late to the party you guys
get my feelings on that here's trevor
noah trevor noah in october 2021 talking
about vaccine mandates in case you think
i'm making up that he's been wrong about
everything this whole time
that's right people vaccine mandates
work
and if you ask me this is a win-win
situation yeah because think about it
it'll help keep everybody safe and it
gets the economy moving again and then
for the people who still didn't get
vaccinated
look i don't think you're right but if
you are
your win
is that we all die
and then you guys inherit the entire
earth
it'll be pretty sweet
for a while until you all die of measles
because you don't believe in vaccines
right
because if you didn't believe in
mandates that means you don't believe in
vaccines so he was pushing mandates
government mandates on people we now
don't know that the vaccines did not
work as promised we know that there's
all sorts of side effects again everyone
should do whatever they want and talk to
their doctor but so i don't know i'm
actually asking you guys like i really
am asking you guys like what is it that
we should do in this situation should we
keep you know we want to keep coaching
these people to get the right way but
he's never going to get there right i
think there's a chance that bill maher
will get there but what do we do do we
just like oh my god you're so great
because you're not wrong a hundred
percent of the time or do we say no
until until you get there we just have
to keep ignoring you or mocking you or
whatever i'm really not sure what the
answer is that's great man you kind of
get it because kyrie irving should be
allowed to play but he should have been
allowed to play the entire time and you
yourself
were mocking people who were against
mandates so someone like him i guess
should be ignored more than anything
else and and not just like oh you get a
treat because you're not a complete
idiot like you're not wrong on
everything
so you get a special button
or a tag a little star for your lapel i
think we have to just not forget and and
then you that it's on you to sort of
curate the people that you can roughly
trust when all hell breaks loose because
obviously all hell bro is going to break
loose again it's it's in the system it
just is